this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
it's Christmas Eve and that means
meeting up with your friends and loved
ones and trying to stop them from
killing each other especially when we
your friends our loved ones or as
polar-opposite as they can get
uncle lies at despair can I have some
water tonight well I suppose you've been
good enough this year honey why don't
you share some of yours yeah oh no
that's no way to treat a child yeah why
don't you raise yours like we raised
hard well I'm pretty sure they did raise
me before I got abandoned in the Balto
Review no that wasn't you pretty sure it
was no we remember the children we
abandoned I don't know about you but I
sure am excited for our Christmas meal
yeah where is it we've been waiting
forever now son don't make us abandon
you like we did her you just save
appeals taking a while because it's
being specially delivered trust me you
only want an expert to deal with
something so perfectly Christmasy as
long as it's edible I'm doing that
explains why your kid looks like she ate
chimney
it tasted like dying well at least we
know where our kid is what are you even
talking about get it hey boy stop
beating back gloom and save some for me
I feel spirits of the year
she won't even share you say something
over there pubic wig hey why don't we
watch a movie the perfect Christmas
interaction where we don't have to have
any interaction home alone - you
couldn't even put on home alone one oh I
love this movie I only like the first
one exactly they've seen it so many
times there's practically background
noise but everyone has interesting
thoughts about home alone - you see when
the original came out in 1990 it was
huge it played at number one for 12
weeks and turned a relatively unknown
child actor Macaulay Culkin into a
megastar so not surprisingly two years
later a sequel came about giving
everybody the same comedy they grew to
love and I do mean the same comedy many
people were angered at how much
repeating there was we using the same
jokes scenarios even teaching the same
lessons that was learned in the original
Macaulay Culkin and director Chris
Columbus even
market in the first films commentary
Johnny you said he could write this on
the weekend I wonder how long it took me
very the second one a little bit cut and
paste and boom you're done sequel BAM
but much like Ghostbusters two people
totally forgot they hated it because
come on well I'm here to see if there's
any validity to that command and look at
a movie that seems to divide many but at
least conserve as a harmless distraction
I'm only watching this for sharknado
star Jon heard a chance this is the
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
and I don't say that often it's true
let's take a gander at home alone - we
start off this rollercoaster a variety
with practically the same music against
the same credits with the same exterior
shot followed by the same interior shot
okay I know you're trying to establish a
style but we don't even need to move the
tripods from your last shoot you might
want to mix it up a bit hopefully
everyone's character traits are repeated
to trip you little sourpuss you're dead
paying good money for did you know what
my own money I go on my own vacation
alone yeah okay let's address what's
arguably one of the biggest problems
with the film Macaulay Culkin's
performance sucks
but it's not really his fault he already
played up the kid who has to act like an
adult in the first film and he
immediately became the biggest star in
the world
and that's not exaggerating he was
everywhere for a while that kind of
attention so quickly so young is gonna
result in this kind of performance the I
don't care I'm cool as shit now
performance didn't mean what he said he
was just sucking up to you at first you
look kind of scary
where I think about it it's not so bad
without any of you guys and it had the
most fun in my whole life it would
happen to you it would happen to me it
would happen to anyone there's really no
blame it's just the situation with that
said let's make fun of this like hell
honey are you packed yet yes yes I'm
trying to see if I can literally phone
in my performance did you see what
grandma Penelope sent you for the trip
an inflatable cloud to play with in the
pool how exciting
can't tell are you excited it's eerily
similar to all the times you actually
are excited Kevin what is it with you
and Christmas trees stay at the
world-renowned Plaza Hotel yeah most of
this opening dialogue you can just
replace with why can't set up for second
or third act pay off bad joke to make it
look like we're not setting up for the
second or third act pay off honey did
you set up for second or third egg pay
off segue to other set up for a second
or third act pay off to make you forget
about this set up for a second or third
act pay off speaking of which kevin has
to grab his tie while his uncle sings in
the shower and decides to record it I do
hope the dollar store microphone on that
thing picks up the clearest audio both
inside and outside the room ironically
Macaulay Culkin might be the only person
from Hollywood not told that yet he
performs on a Christmas pageant with his
brother buzz who proceeds to make fun of
him
[Music]
who's easily amused pageant goers he was
so ready to watch home alone three Kevin
finds out what buzz is doing and punches
him but because this is a family matters
episode now it has to go more
over-the-top funny enough this reveals
that the only character in this sequel
that strangely evolved is buzz I know
that sounds strange seeing how bullies
are always the most underdeveloped
characters but he legitimately grows as
a character he's still a bully but now
he knows how to manipulate his
vocabulary shot up and he seems Whittier
and funnier my prank was immature and
ill-timed Merry Christmas indeed what a
troubled young man
the only downgrade is when he is mean
his word age is a lot more um Disney
Channel Gila trout sniffer lue trout
sniffer that's much more intimidating
then if you're growing on my ass but hey
if you're not a fan of how the language
and this one's more cleaned up than the
last one don't worry there's plenty of
lordship repeated from the first film
fight my own money I go on my own
vacation alone well you got your wish
last year maybe you'll get it again this
year it all depends on how lazy and
rushed the writer is to get his paycheck
up you're in luck you hear that wall
randomly screaming at ah
speed up the film play Williams not
cracker music again rinse repeat
water down this time Kevin makes it at
least as far as the airport with his
family but they get separated and Kevin
gets on the wrong plane we have to close
up here they're ready to go
he dropped his boarding pass plane
camelina bored him but make sure he
locates his family before
well 9/11 hasn't happened yet so go
ahead I have some theories on why 9/11
really happened
really oh look another possibly
debatable funny scene yeah watch this
over and see if you snicker at something
a little odd have you ever been to
Florida was it to yourself
youngbeom has done so more but the
baha'i kinesin now don't get me wrong
this doesn't seem that funny
whatever he looks at the camera because
a guy in a different language won't shut
up but realistically it's the most
nonsensical awkward moment we know he's
supposed to be looking at the audience
but in this situation there is no
audience so imagine you're talking to me
and I suddenly just went that'd be super
weird and why is this guy still talking
he knows Kevin doesn't speak French does
he think he made a friend a friend who
slowly shades you by looking at the
airplane set with more space than any
plane ever built it's actually kind of
hilarious just not at all for the
intended reasons just a feeling we have
everybody there's nothing to worry about
yeah you're right you're right we're
fine
American Airlines losing your luggage
and your kids so kevin of course ends up
in new york and checks to see where he
is is that over there it's new york
[Music]
anyone else feel like Culkin's blank
stares are trying to eat your soul you
taste like innocence
let's do this stick again families in
Florida New York
[Music]
oh come on in the original he had to
really think about it dealing what the
fact that his family was gone but then
think about all the mean things they
said to him here just looks like he
suddenly fob his residual check speaking
of money he uses all the cash in his
dad's bag he accidentally took to see
New York he even checks out sites that
are uncomfortable to say the least you
see was all conspiracy by the Satanists
which is why you can see the face in
smoke feathers yep Kevin passes by a
truck the escaped convict snuck into and
their sequel material is much to be a
scared of smell know what that is fish
its freedom
now it's fish sorry matthew broderick
will master this routine six years later
there's no need in trying to top him
[Music]
onna oh I do hope there's more secretary
from Ghostbusters reboot material with
him big enough coincidence they all
happen to be in New York at the exact
same time but Kevin just misses them
passing in the street
causing Marv to bump into someone come
on let's go why don't that anger him so
much this is a guy who breaks into God
knows how many houses and almost commits
child murder yet speaking French to a
woman was too far imagine how we react
to this guy
Kevin makes his way to the famous Plaza
Hotel but not before coming across a
disturbing character
why I mean okay this is obviously a
retread of the old man gimmick from the
first one but he had a creepy backstory
and could at times look very scary this
is a Susan Boyle and mrs. Doubtfire high
bridge she doesn't look the least bit
frightening is it because she has birds
is that it
birds aren't scary you're literally
feeding them in a later scene if it were
bad to be scary if it was insects it'd
be scary if it was rats
anything but birds there is literally a
Mary Poppins song about this scenario it
is famously charming and that's at least
bit intimidating who knows maybe it was
meant to be a horror film he finally
makes it to the hotel where he comes
across a interesting cameo excuse me
down the hall to the left
Thanks there goes a man who looks like
he'd lose by 3 million votes scuse me
yeah by the pussy
auntie isn't that a man we should be
talking about no no no there's no reason
to talk about him at all the guy got
into politics surely there's no harm in
discussing politics over the holidays
I completely agree I'll start Chapter II
save the day
[Music]
for every one star movie he's in he's
the reason it got that one story Tim
Curry we can all agree on him I'm not
kidding he is once again the best part
of the movie even teaming him with Rob
Schneider can't distract how awesome he
is he plays the concierge who suspects
Kevin of suckering them with a stolen
card and phony story mostly because
their operators are idiots to be fair
that slowdown voice would work a lot
better if he just added two words see
suddenly it seems plausible
participation from McAllister a
reservation for yourself kids going into
hotel making a reservation I don't think
it's that thing he said the last movie
did you get that
give me his credit card so I won't get
to mischief and then sometimes I do get
into mischief they all do it of course
works and Kevin enjoys all the perks of
luxury by the way show of hands how many
people when they hear this song
instantly think of Kevin in swim trunks
yeah me too stupid movie get them credit
that even Rob Schneider gets a few
decent laughs mostly involving a
misunderstanding about tipping I'm sorry
you won the tip I still have some tip
leftover tip that could make like five
of my movies yep or even doing this bit
again it's me Johnny I can smell you
getting off the elevator all anybody
seems to watch in these movies are these
films the Grinch and foreign It's a
Wonderful Life
I say branch out movie but why start now
I was singing the blue monkey last night
you was here and you were smokin with my
brother actually a part of me wishes I
could just watch this film series as
opposed to these home alone instead
somebody crowdfund to get these movies
made we got to see him in there
entirely I believe but my termagant
don't Jesse help me duck in my pond get
down on your knees and tell me you love
me
Oh family-friendly my ass bows down
Harley Quinn and a bullet Phil bloodbath
but don't worry parents he didn't swear
while doing it
[Music]
oh yeah this feels learned I hope we
have fun learning the exact same goddamn
lesson we learned in the exact same
goddamn way in the first one you know
there's a difference between
tear-jerking and tiered jerks
tear-jerking is what the first film did
tear jerks are what the producers of
this film are thinking they could do the
exact same thing again meanwhile curry
in a totally not creepy at all way
stalks a little kids room
housekeeping as dr. Strangelove
come on curry we know you can do better
accents than that no no the diamonds are
here
Kevin sets up in seconds what would take
a solid hour in reality a ploy to fool
the and that's when every adult in the
audience said okay we're not coming back
this is the course we're doing it's
shutting up my kids for a while so just
count your blessings you all better get
the irony that I'm frightened by a clown
the next morning curly tries to
apologize for his actions is my
transportation here out in front sir a
limousine and a pizza okay can we just
do a count of every average word made
amazing by Tim Curry's weird
pronunciations Pizza Pizza Oh Tim I love
you and you're Tim charisma I do hope
your father understands if I was simply
checking the room
I shouldn't I looked at you or the
shower would you ever want to see him
again you clearly haven't watched my
other movies I have a lovely day I will
also give credit that this film has the
greatest looking cheese pizza in movie
history
Wow I don't even know where I got this I
just wanted to cheese pizza so bad I
somehow made it happen
can you share okay you three will get
the pizza they'll get the box
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys here's the best reactions to
what I just reviewed this week home
alone is one of my childhood movies it
was one of my favorite Christmas movies
growing up what he wants us to react to
home alone to the holly jolly rehash and
it really kind of sucks I still kind of
like this equal take a shot of vodka
every time Harry and Marv are supposed
to die in the climax of this movie about
ten bucks will be passed out and roughly
five minutes flat I am like yeah say hi
kitty hi kitty
dad the camera kitty yeah yeah really
still shit though Merry Christmas you
filthy animal and a happy new year you
have opinions a lot of opinions about
movies TV shows even trailers there's so
much to talk about you get emotional
about them just like anybody gets
emotional about them well now you don't
have to wait to get that raw emotion
straight to the Internet why because we
got star does app it allows you
instantly to film your reactions to
movies TV shows and even trailers happy
angry confused whatever it is and
whatever your reaction is Stardust is
there to show it some of the wildest and
craziest reactions are on there and
there's so much fun to watch there's a
lot of variety endless possibilities and
they're definitely worth checking out
I even using myself this week I've
reacted to a lead-up battle angel Star
Wars the last Jedi and of course home
alone - it's there to get the first and
best reaction that you got it's a ton of
fun and 100% free so check out other
people's opinions as well as sharing
your own also stay tuned afterwards to
see how you can be in the next nostalgia
critic
[Music]
[Applause]
curry runs Kevin's credit card to find
out it's stolen but done in one of my
favorite dissolves of all time
[Applause]
[Music]
admit it that was a much more satisfying
live-action Grinch than anything Ron
Howard gave us meanwhile Marvin Harry
planned their next heist while
ice-skating cuz they had the location
hey get over here and drop my
foreshadowing hotels tourists carry lots
of cash boom kaboom there's no
guarantees I got a better idea
well that pointless lion window where
they decide to rob a toy store Duncan's
toy chest which again Kevin happens to
be at yeah I enjoy the economy's that
could keep a place like that open you
got a few years left he ends up talking
to the owner of the store the
schmucker's brand jelly guy he's unaware
at the moment though that he is actually
the owner all that money in that store I
imagine everybody has that kind of money
he tells Kevin that a lot of the profits
will go to a Children's Hospital on
Christmas Eve
so Kevin makes a donation I'm not
supposed to spend this money but I $20
shoveling snow in a jar on our garage so
you can give this to mr. Duncan the
hospital needs it more than I do
oh well that's quite a sacrifice after
riding your limo from your luxury hotel
on your folks bank account $20 I'm sure
is a big deal won't you give more but Mr
Duncan falls for it and gives him a
present of two turtledoves one Kevin
keeps and one he gives to a friend
speaking of sticks guess whose paths
cross again
hi um Todd
okay it's already a huge coincidence
that not only are they in New York but
they're in roughly the same area but how
many times have they accidentally bumped
into each other three times in New York
City
hell even would you plan to meet up it's
impossible half the time these three
have better homing powers than the
keymaster on the gatekeeper oh you
didn't put the hands on the cheeks
restraint he runs away from them and
uses that valuable time not locating a
cop but instead putting beads on a
sidewalk because he's supposed to be a
smart kid remember yes I don't know 90s
we only said those two things we were
pretty dumb Tim Curry puts on his best
show Shire kept preparing to eat
alles face as he confronts Kevin's lies
what's the matter matter matter
store wouldn't take your stolen credit
card let's see what the police have to
say yes police there are two criminals
chasing me that I could use the
protection I ran away I don't want to
get grown a little idiot now we just
have one unfunny pratfall let's shake
things up with another unfunny pratfall
[Music]
show of emotion this looks like a job
for a 1940's audio off of the clearest
speakers on a 10-inch TV hold it right
there you was here last night too wasn't
it yes sir and you were smooching with
my brother I'd love this one look he
gives like did I no no that was another
hotel you're been spoken with everybody
Snuffy al Leo little mo with the gimpy
leg the scene is ungodly childish and
weirdly forced but I'd be lying if I
said I didn't kind of laugh at it
everything from one of them having one
of the names he mentions to Schneider's
hilarious shame faces to still to this
day wondering what bony Bob looks like
cheeks bony Bab tell me you're not
wondering that and of course who can
forget get down on your knees and tell
me you love me I love you how was that
not on a home alone Valentine's Day card
he also got a wonder what he whispered
to himself before saying that line how
is this not the most embarrassing thing
I've ever done
Plaza we thought this was a good
advertising but Kevin comes across
Marvin Harry waiting for him outside
revealing their evil plan of course at
midnight tonight we're hitting Duncan's
toy chest you want to shut up he's not
gonna talk to anybody
it's only been two minutes and over the
end is Tim Curry so much he would have
said anybody like anybody but again
because New York is so tiny they run
across the same woman from before and
Kevin makes it look like they pinched
her ass what oh this is why your time
magazine's Person of the Year
Kevin escapes and gives yet another
great read from his emotionally gripping
voice
[Music]
can we show back-to-back the cries for
his mother from both films you know what
your next call back to the last film
bear be funny as hell or I'm walking you
get lucky the families told that Kevin
is in New York but sadly he's left
wandering the streets and one of the
scarier parts of the city now there's a
guy who has things figured out no
seriously fifty bucks I can do that and
he comes across the scariest one of all
I would say high most kids with your
birds are really cute
he of course befriends her and she takes
him to the top of a concert hall where
insert Church seemed from first one here
I wasn't always like this you know I had
a job I had a home but the man I loved
fell out of love with me that broke my
heart and and whenever the chance to be
loved came along again I ran away from
us wait that's it you went through a
breakup and you ended up here you see
sometimes you can trust a person and
then when things are done they forget
about you they're just too busy wait
I'll make sure I understand this mmm in
love and employed breakup homelessness
there's a missing gap there I feel well
would you mind filling that in look I
admire you're trying to make homeless
people more human but Kevin found the
person with the least homeless issue at
story there's mental illness abuse
financial ruin tough things to confront
and the silver-haired hopeless romantic
is the one representing all that she's
gonna be your icon for what most
homeless people are like what if Kevin
went with the watch it kid guy with his
problems be so quick and easy
to understand who all understand you
must have gone through some heartbreak
maybe your heart maybe just something
you know so not only is this emotionally
empty but it also feels manipulative
which again I guess it's in fitting with
the theme of the movie sniffer oh now we
have some definite opinions on homeless
people yes all their problems can be
solved super easily I know let's talk
about it in great detail we Christmas on
Christmas song I forgot the words
because I'm nervous I'm singing this to
distract you so is it working I suppose
so go on I'm going back to watching home
alone too because it's something I want
to do now is that that that's what I'm
doing beautiful if you need somebody to
trust it can be me I won't forget to
remember you don't make promises you
can't keep
[Music]
we're only cryptic Kevin walks by the
Children's Hospital and decides he wants
to stop the robbery on his own unless
it's a license
can't miss kids on Christmas Kevin goes
to his relatives abandoned house being
renovated puts together another
pointless math seriously minimum half
hour to draw that in this time-sensitive
scenario and John Williams plays the
exact same score from last time because
he's doing Schindler's List you know
he's got real movies to work on
[Music]
ah this is so lame I need my curry fix
what kind of idiots do you have working
here the finest in New York there's a
drink of Gatorade in a marathon I'm
going out to look for him
what your son is lost in one of the
biggest cities in the world there are
hundreds of parasites out there there
are bird and ladies out there madam bird
ladies armed to the teeth do bundle up
it's awfully cold outside a moment of
silence for the last scene of Tim Curry
in this film after Duncan's toy chest
closes down politely leaving the lights
on and all the money in the register
our thieves look over their riches I
won't have to do Christmas story - after
this no the punchline - what I just said
thankfully Kevin knew Harry would land
on the left side of the window and Marv
on the right as he watches the other
into the air okay somewhere we went from
Three Stooges destruction to Avengers
destruction that's the crash Batman
makes after falling from a building and
heavy armor this is a sure to tell him
from a tumbling act the damage he would
have made could be buffered out they
chase into the building where they think
they have him cornered we got plus the
last time because we underestimated that
little bundle of misery the scene like
the last time clearly you have not been
watching this movie honey camera and we
won't hurt you you'll never hear from us
again yeah they need those pictures so
people won't be looking for them which
people already are hi and in keeping
with the earlier TV scene we get yet
another incredibly lazy yet somehow
weirdly funny moment okay kid here we go
let's do it the first big home trap in
home alone two
Oh brick that's our first big trap a
blatant blood brutal brick no turning
wheels or strings or anything
complicated it's just a brick but to
make things even stranger he does it
again it's almost like a troll joke home
alone to the genius trap set up it's
like the best thing these films are
known for and we just watch a guy get
hit with a brick for like two or three
minutes I'm sorry I know it's dumb but
it's ingeniously dumb after that it goes
the course you'd pretty much suspect
they both tried different ways to get in
and are met with a bunch of traps some
are okay some are lame they're hit and
miss to say the least but even God gets
sick of Kevin shit and gives them a bit
of his own medicine you may have won the
battle a little dude but you lost the
war the home alone sequels in a nutshell
so what they're gonna make him go
through the goofy traps like they said
they would in the last one Jesus Christ
he has a gun shit just got real okay if
this was a Scorsese film he'd be on his
fifth bullet catch me lucky charms
asshole sure enough Birds arrived to fly
slightly to the right of them and the
police finally show up because you don't
mess with kids on Christmas but you
don't call the cops until maybe 20
minutes Disney slapstick Kevin clearly
did the right thing we missed the
presents he made us hide out in his door
so we could steal all the kiddies
charity money what an out of nowhere
confession even for a dumper isn't a
make Kevin's mom continues to search the
city when she finally gets the idea of
where he would be where no one else
would be on Christmas Eve here's a fun
game try to count how many times you
actually believe what he's saying I'll
check back every mean thing I ever said
to my family you wouldn't say no to that
I don't care I love all hot spots yeah
I just see my mother would've worn
another thing as long as much emotion
but suppose I just want my mother
sometime anytime even if it's just once
and only for a couple minutes
oh what a roller coaster I sure hope he
finds that Blue Fairy
what's that he's not the emotionless
robot from a guy
the mother finds him though and takes
him back to the hotel the reunion is so
underwhelming they literally sleep
through it
yeah next shot they're all asleep how
good everybody felt when they all
reunited in the first one oh yeah I
guess he knows we're Jewish it looks
like mr. Duncan was grateful to Kevin
though for saving his money so we got
them all gifts making this already
richest hell family even richer again
the stories of 90s economy but Kevin
realizes there's one gift he forgot to
give as long as you each have a
Turtledove we'll be friends forever oh
great like I don't have enough friggin
birds
Oh trust me don't make promises you
can't because we haven't first movies
enough Oh would you like to join us at
our hotel oh nevermind Merry Christmas
enjoy the freezing cold I'm sorry I
still have some thoughts on that whole
homeless thing that's due on well maybe
we have some things to say about that to
stay here in total uncomfortable silence
until I get back here's your Christmas
tree thank you well aren't you going to
invite me in for dinner
you don't want be a part of this I
believe you Lee this gingerbread house
of angst ho ho and that's what I think
we should do with homeless people every
single - okay who's ready for some
amazing food yeah those homeless both
need to get a job what I mean if we just
keep giving everything to them they're
never gonna get back on their feet
we need stricter laws really well I
completely disagree these people have
gotten the worst life has to offer
yeah and we should give them as much
support and care as possible really well
I guess we'll just have to agree to
disagree
agreed why be adults if we can't accept
our differences on despair is this the
thing you're always trying to teach me
called acceptance yes it is sweetheart
and those people across the table seem
to be pretty good at it
thank you
really hungry me tool once you got to
eat there critic oh well since this
wasn't quite the nuclear explosion I
thought it would be I guess we can go
ahead and eat this is my favorite meal
to have this time of year Oh also
excited yeah
Christmas crunch huh you brought cereal
as the main course dude it's not just
cereal it's Christmas crunch it's the
greatest Christmas cereal ever made
never been a fan of it myself
what yeah Odie's anything but I stay far
away from Christmas Chris you're joking
I always found it to be a generic
offshoot yeah you just slap Christmas on
it and suddenly it's something
completely different remain calm here
too much sugar for me oh yeah I mean
just one bowl of this stuff will give
you diabetes if I read kiddo she knows
nothing to get upset about here I think
I'd rather eat the box it came in right
critic there's you blasphemy Christmas
drugs have you no heart have you no so
Christmas you can find it up yeah
monsters monsters all of you you do not
deserve to eat Christmas crunches
prostate Sonia you are choosing shit
that's what you betrayers are Judas is
shit I hope you rot for all eternity and
specially the children shame oh maybe
Christmas so it is Merry Christmas
I guess I've been talking for an entire
24 hours 26 but who's counting oh my god
I am so sorry I totally exploded and
ruin everybody's evening I I'll go get
your carrots hold on hold on there's no
need for that
you had an outburst it happens you
apologized didn't saw the error of your
ways we're okay
really yeah we know that deep down
you're a good kid just nuts clearly no
doubt bug juice well well thank you that
really means a lot to me you guys would
forgive me after all that
you guys really are a lot like home
alone too
wow I don't believe this how are we in
any way like home alone - not everything
ties into a movie you're reviewing well
that's what guys it is annoying
predictable and not always giving its
all but it surprises you sometimes
there's still moments that make you glad
you saw it and though they're not there
all the time those moments don't go a
long way it pisses me off to no end in
many respects yeah I also find myself
coming back to it every year like a
strange comfort food that doesn't taste
good but it's still cozy and familiar oh
you mean like Christmas cry do not that
is delicious
the film has too many flaws to count but
that's also part of what makes it kind
of fun just how phoned in parts of it
are mixed in with new elements that are
legitimately good I know it's a weird
way to explain it but the feelings many
people have for it are weird - including
my own it's not always good but it's
harmless and familiar mixed with just
enough enjoyable moments to make it
worth it in the end I'm the Nostalgia
Critic and people really are kind of
like movies some you can be around some
you can't but they're always worth a
shot
happy holidays and enjoy your Christmas
feed on second thought we have been up
for 24 hours what do you say we take a
nap sounds good
shut that door hey guys here's even more
reactions to what I just reviewed this
week when it comes to sequels most of
the time they don't do as well as the
original film for home alone - I like it
as much as the first movie home alone -
is the best home alone and a great
holiday feel it's still just as funny I
loved Kevin's antics and it's a fun
watch I can't hate this film I really
can't I can't find a reason tape this
film you want your reaction to be in the
next nostalgia critic next week we'll be
reviewing Star Wars the last Jedi just
download the Stardust app at the link
below follow us at nostalgia critic
record your reaction and then tweet it
to us with this hashtag or use Facebook
the ones we like best will make it in
the next nostalgia critic video we
absolutely love going through and seeing
everybody's different reactions the
over-the-top one's the funny ones
there's such a wide variety out there
and we love watching them and you will
too so download the app get out there
and show us your crazy reactions
[Music]
[Applause]
have a lovely day
hey folks so this Wednesday December
20th we are gonna be doing a charity
drive we haven't done one of these in a
while and we're really excited to do it
we are doing it for st. Jude's Hospital
it is starting at 6:00 p.m. Central time
we're gonna keep it low-key we kind of
want to talk with you guys that's what a
lot of it's gonna be about we're gonna
be showing videos and joking around and
stuff like that but a lot of it's gonna
be kind of interacting with you and
we're gonna allow you guys to call in
and stuff like that so I did it keep
posted on how how that'll have happened
and of course be you know an incentive
to give it is a charity drive but yes
that is definitely something we really
want to do I because we like talking
with our fans we're gonna try and have a
lot of channel awesome crew there that
you know does like and establish your
critics and stuff but we're also gonna
have Brad Jones it's gonna be an and
Chris Duckman is gonna be in for no
particular reason I don't
maybe we're filming something I don't
know but yes definitely check that out I
don't know how long we're gonna go you
know we're just gonna go until you know
until we can't really go that much more
you know but I mean this thing usually
lasts like you know maybe six hours or
something like that so so that'll go for
a bit and it's gonna be streaming on our
YouTube channel and it's gonna be
streaming live so if you want to see it
go there we're gonna be going through
GoFundMe to you know to handle the money
and everything and we are gonna have
prizes as well the big giveaways are
gonna be a Nintendo switch with games as
well and the Nintendo 3ds XL super Ness
Edition with games as well so yeah
definitely
um definitely go ahead and check us out
see if you can give a call and so forth
and definitely give this is a great
organization and like I said we do
charity shout outs at the end of our
videos but we haven't done a charity
drive in a while we even done of stream
in a really long time so we really want
to you know do want these again
especially when we have people in town
so definitely tune in it's gonna be a
lot of fun it's gonna be very chilled
and laid-back
you know it's it's one of those things
where we find out a lot of times just
having a cool conversation with cool
people is enough and you know even
people just playing games sometimes is
enough you know so where you just want
to have a lot of time - a lot of fun
just chilling with you guys and talking
with you and like I said definitely give
- same shoes they do amazing work and
they help so many people so definitely
check that out I'm gonna look over my
list see if there's anything else that I
missed here doesn't look like it so yeah
that's about it guys thank you so much
for watching and hopefully we'll see you
there take care
you